this morning russia's government said it
would not let talks with u.s officials
drag on the u.s is trying to prevent a
possible invasion of ukraine a russian
neighbor and a u.s ally diplomats from
both sides met yesterday and those talks
are set to resume tomorrow nancy cordes
is at the white house nancy good morning
good morning both sides nate say the
conversations so far have been frank but
no big breakthroughs yet in these talks
that are being watched by governments
around the world very high stakes here
speaking to reporters in geneva
yesterday russian's deputy foreign
minister insisted
we have no plans no intentions to attack
ukraine there's no reason to fear some
sort of escalation scenario and yet the
russians have made no moves to pull back
the roughly 100 000 troops that are
amassed along the ukrainian border now
in these talks the russians are
demanding that ukraine and other former
soviet territories not be allowed to
join nato or align themselves with the
west well that is a total non-starter
for u.s officials though they do say
they are discussing a possible deal to
pull back u.s and russian missile
systems in the region they're hoping
that that would be enough to mollify the
russians now tomorrow the talks move to
brussels where nato is headquartered the
u.s looking to show the russians that
the u.s and europe are in lockstep and
ready to impose
serious massive sanctions on russia if
it does invade ukraine
nancy thank you very much